[Music]
we walked over to guy Ferry's Vegas
kitchen and started with this insane
nacho platter there was chips everywhere
cheese everywhere but who's going to
complain about
that and then we kind of delve into the
rest of the menu with some drinks some
small plates some burgers some fries
it's safe to say we gained about 10 lbs
on this Vegas trip but we love
[Music]
food lastly we finished off at Bugsy and
my steakhous and I love steak so I was
so stoked to be here we had some drinks
some soup some side dishes and then we
got into the steak which was obviously
the best part that was at least until we
got to the dessert I was already way too
full to fully enjoy it but it was
delicious